hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on monster hunter world again
and today we're gonna be talking about
deviljho the new monster that has just
been added to monster hunter world and
how to defeat him solo so like always
let's get started so if you're not
entirely familiar deviljho is the newest
monster added to a monster hunter world
and can be only found as of right now
through expeditions and quests the
question specific have to be 6 or 7 star
quests and the expedition's have to be
in the high-ranked I was looking around
each area of the game and by the rotten
veil for me at least there was a
question mark Bioware one of the
monsters should have been located so I
knew that he would be there and sure
enough he was if you're doing an
expedition you're basically going to
have to take a shot in the dark a your
area first off you want to be looking at
all of the areas all the recess rotten
Vale and see if where the location says
where has the three monsters located if
any of them have question marks and you
have all the monsters in the game
definitely go to that one but if it's
none of them take a shot in the dark
with one of them and hopefully he
happens to be there if you have a
definite way to actually find him going
through expeditions leave it in the
comments below so that other hunters can
know and be well notified like normal
with all these videos we're gonna look
at his physiology report and then going
to these suggested equipment movesets
for the devil Joe and then finally some
overall tips at the end to help you out
in the fight just a little bit more so
let's get started going based off the
report his head and belly are his weak
points with the head tail and belly
being breakable or severable in terms of
weapon choice it doesn't matter since
all the weak points - all do three star
damage with every weapon so it's
entirely up to you whether you want to
use a heavy bow gun dual blades hammer
insect glaive entirely up to you for
weaknesses double joe is weakest -
thunder and dragon the most with fire
and water and all other ailments being a
two star for me I happen to use fire and
ice which if you don't know is a blast
and ice type of dual blade so I
definitely had a disadvantage going into
this fight but I did not know his
weaknesses at the time I probably should
have stuck with the newark agon take
gloves that i got for the recommended
equipment I suggest mega potions and max
potions for obvious reasons the vitality
mental to negate some damage and the
Rocksteady mantle because you can negate
the impact of a stomp attack which we'll
get to in a little bit sadly though if
you are one of the people that haven't
gotten past a char 50 you cannot get the
Rocksteady mental so if you're just
meeting devil Joe for the first time and
you're in the star six to seven I
believe we do have access to the
vitality mantle so all is still good
there no berries as well I recommended
he has a spray attack that will hit you
with dragon blight which we'll get into
in a little bit as well and dunk pod
since he will spawn on expeditions and
invade your quests you're going to need
these to get rid of the other monsters
out of your way or you're going to be
double-teamed now that that's over with
let's get into the move set and for the
first move we're gonna be talking about
in his moveset the first attack is this
head thrust he will basically pull back
and then thrust his head forward to
knock you down you can run away from
this move or dodge left to right to
evade this move I don't I do not
recommend dodging forward or backward as
you could possibly still get hit by the
move the next move is this foot stomper
this will do minor damage similar to
knock back the image if you're aware of
that and then make you struggle a little
bit to get up if you're affected by it
like I said using the rock steady mental
will negate all of this allowing you to
put pressure on him while he does this
move the other variation of this move is
the pounce attack which is the same
exact thing applies though it just
depends on whether you're farther away
or close by to determine what variation
he uses another is this three hit swipe
attack it will quickly lift his head up
and go right to left then left to right
and then back to right to left again as
shown in the clip if that description
was a little bit too confusing if you're
hit by this tack and you get knocked on
the floor don't move and let him finish
or you will get hit again if you try to
get up so wait until he's finished
especially if you're hit by the first
move because if we try to get up you'll
get hit on the third move if you tried
to move so like I said just wait until
he's finished while you're on the ground
because you do have invincibility frames
there and cannot be hit while you're on
the floor Phoenix move is his tail swipe
double Joe has one of the longest tails
in the game definitely so you definitely
want to watch out for this move even if
you think you're safe you can either
dodge backwards away from him and get
out of range or forwards if you're close
enough toward the closer or to the
bigger part of his tail so you can dive
into that underbelly and then attack his
stomach this move usually occurs when
you're behind him so definitely be aware
if you're trying to attack his rear and
trying to cut his tail obviously cutting
his tail is going to decrease how much
range he has with that tail swipe since
he will still do it so if you do want to
cut his talent and negate that it's
entirely up to you I went the whole
fight really without really cutting the
tail I believe I cut it toward the end
so it wasn't really big of an issue for
me but that's entirely up to you and
your entire choice the next move is this
trucking type move I really don't know
how to explain it but he basically
pushes forward and knocks you with his
side sending you flying back if you're
hit by it you can tell he will do this
when he backs up and does a mini roar
and then charges forward dodging
sideways and not towards him is going to
be your best option because the tail can
clip you on this move so watch out and
try to dodge away from him as soon as
possible if you're basically around his
side area so about the middle of his
stomach you definitely want to dodge the
closer towards the head and not the tail
because like I said the tail being
incredibly long you have a lot of
distance to dodge and then the last move
is the spray attack we talked about
earlier double-g will basically back up
and race his head high in the air and
release this spray of red gas that gives
you dragon blade and dragon blade
nullifies your weapons elemental
properties you can cure this by simply
eating one nil berry
it does say elemental I'm not entirely
sure if that it also means the elements
like blasts stun and poison and all that
but it obviously does mean elemental
fire ice water thunder dragon all that
type of stuff if anyone knows in the
comments or if anybody knows that's
watching the video please tell me in the
comments below if it also includes
ailments so like I said other hunters
can know as well this move has about
medium range on it so either dodging
backwards out of range of it or dodging
forwards if you're close enough and
getting some free hits while he's doing
this attack is completely fine usually
if you guys have seen most of my solo
guides you know I cover the areas in
which you fight these monsters in except
this time it's a little bit different
since you can basically fight him in
just about every location I'm assuming I
happen to fight him in the rotten Vale
but I know for a fact that you don't
have to fight him in the rotten value
can be fighting him in the ancient
forest wilds player waste or the coral
Highlands all that stuff so basically
just understand your environment and use
it to your advantage if those alleged
use it for mounting if there's para
toads and near a toads use those as well
to blow them up or paralyze him because
he can get paralyzed but but there is a
quick tip we will mention later in the
video regarding that but like I said
just use the environment to your
advantage and you should be completely
fine sadly I will not I cannot go over
every single area in the game because
I'm not entirely well-equipped and know
every single thing in every inch of
every map and then lastly to end the
video we have some tips I would like to
share the first one in particular is
then once after you beat him the first
time you ever encounter one in the
expedition you want to go back to Astrea
and go to the blue exclamation point
right in front of you it's going to be a
bunch of scholars they're basically
gonna be talking about how Devil Joe is
in the new world and he's [ __ ] up the
ecosystem again but more importantly
after you collect enough tracks you're
going to be getting a special
to kill another deviljho I don't want to
go into specifics on what the thing is
there really isn't huge spoilers but
just in case anybody doesn't want it I'm
not going to share it but basically the
main assignment is to kill the devil Joe
so you can use that is going to be any
special assignments tab underneath
events it's going to be the fifth
I believe it's the sixth fifth or sixth
type of tab at the bottom when you go to
join a quest and it's going to be
highlighted in red for you next tip is
that Devil Joe can be trapped since he
isn't an elder dragon but he's the only
monster I believe at this time that can
actually fight back instead of letting
me get free hits you can also capture
him if you want like I chose to do but
like I said he will fight back but
regardless he can still be son
tranquilized if you use the tranq bombs
after you capture him so definitely if
you're trying to lure him into a pitfall
trap or a type of shock trap definitely
be aware he willed that he will fight
back and try to bite you for the next
tip if you're attacked by move such as
the red spray move or the brute attack
or any of that type of stuff like the
three move hit combo you basically want
to sit on the floor and don't move we
talked about this earlier but to
reiterate being on the ground it gives
you invincibility frames allowing you to
completely negate certain damage that
would otherwise hit you so slow down and
don't jump the gun too much and let him
finish the move let him chill out and
then you can get up and start attacking
him for this fight you also want to be
sitting underneath Javal double joe for
most of the fight like I said to evade
some of his dangerous moves so try to
dodge on forward on most of his attacks
like the spray and other stuff to get
underneath him and get in a few free
hits because he is very very aggressive
and then the last one is talking about
his two phases double Joe has two phases
if you've already fought him then you
will definitely know what is the normal
one and then the next one is the enraged
one the enraged one you can tell when
it's active is because he also roars
right before it and his back is reddish
orange in his normal phase his legs are
also weak and should be targeted if you
can't get the head but if in his enraged
form his legs do half damage so if he's
enraged you want to hit for the belly or
the head and if normal phase go for the
legs since they are safer like usual
with these videos it like I said if you
have any other tips or advice that I
didn't mention leave it in the comments
below for all their hunters to learn so
we can all be well equipped for that
double gel fight that is going to be the
video guys hopefully you guys enjoyed
that and hopefully you're now well more
to fight deviljho he was actually a
little bit easier than I predicted I
thought he was going to be this tough
monster maybe that was just my
interpretation of him maybe that was
what the cuz I know deviljho is in the
past Monster Hunter games from the
community from what I've been hearing
from the veteran players he was actually
a lot more difficult so I feel that
maybe they dumped him down a bit whether
that be for new players or just because
he's in the sixth SR or six or seven
star ranking stuff like that but like I
said that's going to be the end of the
video today guys if you guys did enjoy
that be sure to give it a like really
does help me out subscribe if you're new
I'm gonna be covering more stuff with
these solo guides well like I said one
more monsters come in there's also going
to be a new event coming in the next
couple of weeks I got tons of guides on
I'm gonna be coming out with tons of
guides on how to do some of that stuff
so definitely stay tuned for that I'll
keep you up to date on that
my two most recent videos are gonna be
on-screen except this time it's going to
be one recent video and then a playlist
this playlist is going to link you to
every single solo guide that I've done
that includes diablo snark egg on teh
the three elder dragons II know all that
stuff I don't want to spoil too much
about any of the monsters but any of the
higher ranked monsters especially in
high ranked the Elder Dragons I've done
guides for them so if there's a chance
that you are struggling with one of
those monsters click the playlist and
find the video and it will take you
right to it thank you guys for the love
and support on these solo guides they
seem to be some of my more popular
Monster Hunter videos as well as my mom
of my most popular videos in general so
I appreciate all the support on those
you guys were the best but either way
guys that's going to be the end hope you
enjoyed and with that guys I hope you
have a great rest of your day and peace
out